hello everyone and welcome to an
incredible game from the pro chess
League it is the Saint Louis archbishops
versus the Croatia Bulldogs Alice Lee
affidan master Alice Lee versus Grand
Master bogdon Daniel dayak and it's
quite a matchup you can see there's a
quite a bit of a difference in raiding
she's 23 20 and he's 2700 but she's uh
three times a world youth champion and
she already has two International Master
norms and one uh women Grandmaster Norm
so uh she she is definitely progressing
very very fast but this game uh you you
will really enjoy so let's check it out
and see uh why why everyone is
suggesting it so Alice has the white
pieces and she opens with Pawn to D4 uh
Bogdan goes for F5 he goes for the Dodge
defense with Knight to F3 Knight to F6
and now Pawn to G3 we have G6 Bishop G2
Bishop to G7 and now Castles by both
players castles castles we have C4 uh
The Landing Rod variation of the Dutch
with D6 and Knight the C3 so this is all
very standard and there are thousands of
games being played this way uh c6b3 with
Queen to A5 now going after the Knight
Bishop to B2 and now Pawn to E5 striking
in the center D captures D captures
Ponte A3 and now Pawn to E4 and now you
could move the Knight but let's throw in
a nice B4 first and now there is a game
where Queen to C7 was played but here we
have Queen to d8 and it is not as of
move 12 then we have a completely new
game and where our game basically begins
so uh she could avoid a queen trade she
could play some like Knights the D4 she
could put the Knight to G5 but she goes
for the queen trade so captures captures
and now Knight to G5 we have H6 of
course the Knight cannot remain on such
a powerful square and now she doesn't
just go back with the Knight she plays a
rook 8 to D1 uh point being that uh if
bogdon just trades let's say Rook
captures Rook captures age captures and
G5 she has a rook to d8 to check and she
will pick come in the bishop on C8 so
instead after this rotate the D1 move
Rook to E8 was played and now we have
Knight the H3 the Knight is now coming
to F4 Knight B to D7 and now Knight to
B1 we have knighted the B6 attacking the
C4 Pawn Knight the D2 defending and now
Bishop to East 6 piling up on that C4
Pawn so C5 now and not Knights the a for
putting pressure on the bishop Bishop to
A1 and now rook a38 and bognan can be
very very happy with his development
he's developed all of his pieces he
controls um a whole lot of the board and
uh well it's not going to be easy to
find the moves for for Alice but she of
course will try Knight to F4 she goes
after the G6 pawn bishop to F7 gets the
bishop out of harms away and also
defends the pawn on G6 with E3 and now
Pawn to G5 of course he will not allow
the knights to remain in such a
beautiful Square Knight to E2 and now
Bishop to H5 now allowing the Knight to
move but also threatening just to pick
up the Knight so here we have Ponte F3
again played with a very nice tactic e
captures an F3 Bishop captures with
Bishop captress Knight captures and now
you can't go after the pawn because the
rook and d8 would hang so first you have
to trade on D1 captures captures and now
Rook captures on E3 but she finds Bishop
captures on F6 Bishop captures and
Knight F to D4 so she is down a pawn
against a very strong Grand Master but
she is threatening to pick up the F5
Pawn so Rook the E4 the pawn isn't
really threatened at the moment because
if you capture then the Knight on E2
hang so King to F2 now she is
threatening to pick up the pawn but now
Knight the B2 attacking the rook and D1
we have Rook the D2 now comes Knight the
C4 attacking The Rook once again Rook to
D3 and now Knight to E5 really harassing
that Rook Rook back the D to end only
Now Pawn to F4 we have e characters on
F4 G captures and now Pawn to H3 not
allowing Knight to G4 with check and
here we have King to F7 here Bishop page
for check would have been a little bit
better uh but he goes King to F7 and now
Knight to F5 which is a very annoying
threatening Knight to D6 check to pick
up the Rook but also threatening the
pawn here uh it's still uh uh fairly
okay for black uh because King to G6 now
attacks the Knight Knights the D6
attacks the rook and Bishop to H4 check
now as black controls all of these
squares you have to go back King to F1
and now Rook to E3 goes after the H3
Pawn so Knight captures an F4 with check
King to G5 and not Knight the G2 uh
putting pressure on the bishop here but
just the Rook to F3 with Chuck King to
E2 and now Rook captures on H3 with
Knight captures on B7 and The Rook
captures on A3 so a couple of Trades
happened uh and uh at the end of this
variation Bogdan is up a pawn but is
there counter play uh Pawn to B5 she
finds a very very interesting way of of
complicating things she gives up another
Pawn for uh for what can only be
described as a very deadly attack C
captures them B5 and now Rook to D5 and
we reach a position that is so
complicated it seems that it was too
complicated for uh even for a 2700 Grand
Master to solve in a rapid game because
now
uh there are a couple of options first
how do you stop C6 because the Knight
will not be able to capture the Knight
is pinned so there are a couple of
options you could play King to F6 which
kinda moves the king away from the
defense of the bishop but it is possible
to play it like this uh you would get
Knight captures on H4 now B4 black also
will start advancing his Pawn C6 now
Knight captures on C6 Rook the D6 with
check and now it seems like you're gonna
lose the Knight as well luckily there's
King G5 attacking the Knight and if
Knight to F3 check there's also King the
F4 now you're threatening to pick up the
Knight here and there's really nothing
better Rook captures Rook captures on F3
or you could first uh give a nice check
for example Rook checks then the king
moves then you capture here and okay
you're down at night but you have three
extra pawns uh should be enough for a
draw so this is one way to play this if
you want a part with your piece there is
another way however and this one is the
the more complicated one Rook the A2
with check and now the point is you
cannot go
um to help out with the defense of the
night if you play King to F1 then Bishop
to G3 defends the Knight and now there's
really no way to push this for a win if
if Pawn to C6 you're just gonna play
King to G4 and now if C7 there's Rook to
F2 with check King to E1 and Knight the
F3 with check King to D1 and now you
just pick up the pawn bishop captures on
C7 and black is just much much better so
what you would have to do after Rook day
to check is not go King to F1 you have
to play King to D1 uh chess is sometimes
weird like this and now uh Rook captures
on G2 uh Pawn to C6 now advances the
pass pawn and now King to F4 we have
Pawn to C7 and now Rook to G1 with check
with King to C2 and now Rook the G2 with
check King to B3 and now uh there is
nothing
um to be done here you have to settle
for a drop you could try something like
a rook the G3 with check but also night
the C4 is very nice because this is now
impossible if you go for for uh for the
queen then you get Rook the B2 with
check and you will win back the the
White Queen let's say King to C3 you
play B4 with check and now either you
capture the Knight and then Rook the C
to check picks up the queen or you move
King to D3 and now Rook the D to check
forces the capture of the Knight King
characters on C4 Rook C2 check King
captures and now you pick up the queen
uh and you are up two pawns chances are
you are winning this game so very very
complicated but in order to play this
you have to find Rook to a to check or
at least this um uh King uh King to F6
move which gives up the the bishop and
H4 but in the game Bishop to G3 was
played and now it's much much different
uh she plays Pawn to C6 and now uh the
only way to play this is to find King to
G6 and it's not an easy move to find now
the point is if Pawn to C7 you have Rook
to A2 which check and after King to D1
you have rooked the A1 with check and
after King to C2 you have Knight to D3
look at this move who finds who finds
such a move uh and now either you're
capturing the pawn or there's a rook to
see one check uh capturing the pawn
doesn't matter even if you bring your
queen into the game still just Rook to
see one check you give up the Knight and
then Rook captures Queen and it's a draw
but Bogdan didn't find King to G6 he
played Rook to C3 which makes perfect
sense he just puts the Rook behind the
pass Pawn that's how chess is played you
know when we start playing this is what
they teach us but now she is completely
winning so feel free to pause the video
and try to find this the only winning
idea uh to win this game while I give
you a couple of seconds
yeah
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on blocking uh the
the black rook and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is Knight
to C5 so congratulations you found that
you are a true Master of the end game
and now uh there really is no way uh to
block this you you don't control the C
file and the Knight cannot move as the
Knight is pinned from The Rook on D5 so
here Rook the C2 check was played King
to D1 and now King captures
um uh Rook captures on GQ was played
Pawn to C7 there's no stopping promotion
Rook the G1 check King to C2 Rook the G2
check avoiding all of the checks with
the Knight you don't want to allow an
eye to check and then Bishop captures on
C7 she just played King to B3 and it was
in this position and move 50 that Bogdan
Daniel Dak resigned to the game as there
is nothing more to be done here uh
whatever you do next move C8 Queen is
coming and there's just no counter play
you have no you do not have enough
material to tackle the queen and you
can't even go for some like Knight to C
for Fall by Rook G2 check maybe you
could you know figure something out with
with the network and Bishop but the
Knight is still can't move so it's your
first half to waste the move and it's
just uh too many moves there's no way no
way to play this so yeah after uh King
to B3 he resigned and a brilliant
brilliant victory for a 13 year old
maybe she's 14 but I think she's 13 13
year old affili Master Alice Lee against
a 2700 Grand Masters uh epic stuff right
there and yeah the St Louis started
Bishops defeat the Croatia bulldogs as
also
um uh uh Carolina won his game against
Chihuahua and the match was concluded at
three to one uh so yeah that's the game
I hope you guys enjoyed it thank you for
such a wonderful uh suggestion I would
like to thank Ricky black I love you
Sonu Peter giberson Matthew Benoit and
uh Andrea vudelia for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day